(klaxons)
anniversaire de l'arrivée
du convoi des camionneurs
à Ottawa, à la fin janvier.
Et un des organisateurs
planifie déjà l'édition 2023,
qui devrait avoir lieuuu
17 au 20 février. Même s'il
promet une version écourtée
manifestants à l'extérieur
du centre-ville, ctatains
s'inquiètent.é,é,é,é,é,é,é,é,é,,
- Ça me stresse.
Ce n'était pas joli,
la dernière fois.
- Le député Fergus espèpapapapa.
- J'espère de voir une belle
coordination entre nos services
policiers pour s'assurercucucuc.
- Justement, la conseillère
à la sécurité nationale et au
renseignement auprès du p
ministre Justin Trudeau affirme
que des conseillers prcicipaux
se rencontrent pour planifier
la réaction du gouve
à la venue d'un nouveau convoi.
Lors d'une compatition devant
le Comité mixte spécial,
Jody Thomas a
hauts fonctionnaires se sont
rencontrésetette semaine.
Le secrétaire adjoint au bureau
du Conseil Privé soutient queoné
leur approche face
aux manifestations,
comme lors du Rolling Thunder
en avril, inspircacacacacacacacn
des choses ont changé depuis
février.
De son côté, la police
d'Ottawa ne commente pas
le dossiersusususususususususust
les événements à venir
qui pourraient avoir des
répercussions dans la ville.
DAN
Saint-Boniface - Saint-Vital
- J'aimerais voir qu'on soit
plus préparés que la dernière
fois, certainement. C'était
pour le monde qui vit ici.
ALAIN RAYES, député indépendtt
Richmond - Arthabaska
- Avant le gouvernement,
ça devrait êevevevevevevevevever
appris, j'imagine, de ce qui
s'est pruiuit. Et je pense
que ces gens-là, s'ils n'ont
pas compris le message de
la popsasasasasasasasasasasasasa
faire avec eux autres.
JUSTIN TRUAUAU,
premier ministre du Canada
- Je pense qu'on a beaucoup
appris. Je m'attends à ce que
policiers disposent soient
mis en place pour assurer
'o'on n'ait pas une répétition
de l'occupation qui a fait mal
à énormément de gens.
il sera difficile d'accéder à
la rue Wellington, qui deueure
complètement fermée à
la circulation et dont la
réouverture n'est pas prévue
de sitôt, signe qu'à Ottawa,
on ne veut pas revivre
les événements de l'hiver
rnrnier.
Ici Frédéric Pepin,
Radio-Canada, Ottaw